[Musica]
sono molto contento di poter finalmente
avevo un pubblico anche i giovani faccio
l'insegnante formatore degli altri
insegnanti e spesso la casa insegnante
non è così giovane
quindi voglio raccontarvi però questo
capovolgiamo la scuola è il mio ultimo
libro dove raccontano l'esperienza di
questi quattro anni in cui insieme un
gruppo di tanti altri insegnanti abbiamo
creato una realtà bellissima segnati che
praticano una scuola completamente
diversa rispetto a quella cui siamo
abituati noi vi voglio raccontare questo
però perché ho anche avuto la
possibilità di entrare dentro la
macchina del tempo si macchina del tempo
della nasa che ci ha permesso di mi ha
permesso di andare nel 2035 sì perché mi
sono sempre chiesto come sarà la scuola
fra 15 anni fra vent'anni e vediamo un
attimo che cosa riusciamo a vedere
attraverso questa macchina del tempo un
open day del 2030 dove i bambini
addirittura scelgono le maestre e
ingemar in genitori scelgono e maestre
che poi non sarebbe una idea poi così
malvagia forse avremmo anche meno
studenti che al coltello ogni insegnante
io vedendo i pugni ecco il se potessero
scegliere queste questa cosa per cui
questi genitori dicevano fra di loro ma
scelgo quella maestra che sa parlare
bene l'inglese ossia lo guida perché
farlo è molto brava nel trattare i
bambini
sì quella triste però non la voglio
quella lì che è meglio che con mio
figlio proprio non ci deve stare
ecco questa in questa realtà di scuola
ma anche così bella perché è molto più
bella rispetto a quei quei manufatti di
cemento dove siamo abituati è una scuola
che sta un po in aperta campagna
questa è veramente e la scuola di
secondaria inferiore
cinque anni dopo questo bambino è stato
è stato accolto in una scuola un po più
grande un po più avanzata una scuola nel
bosco la chiamavano perché sta nel 2000
nel 2035 la città sono molto meglio
collegata rispetto al presente
ecco ci sono treni molto veloci che
portano fuori della città ci sono
autobus senza autista che se ne vanno in
giro portano ovunque le persone con
facilità e quindi della gente preferisce
abitare fuori della città è piuttosto
che nel caos
e in questa scuola del bosco che vi ho
appena fatto vedere qui vabbè si pagano
anche tassa scolastica però c'è anche un
sacco di educazione fisica e ginnastica
di sport quindi quelle quelle cose che
noi paghiamo extra nella scuola dalla
fine fanno parte tutte di questa retta
di questa scuola così funzionanti c'è
molta c'è molto sport e mo di ragazzi
lavorano tantissimo in tanti sport
diversi si divertono quando è necessario
ed imparano una disciplina sportiva
e poi c'è un in genere note voce c'è una
bellezza di ambienti puliti accogliente
e poi quando un ragazzo era arrivati
trovo all'accoglienza di altri di altri
studenti che sono contenti di stare lì
deve quindi lo salutano come un amico le
mense scolastiche e poi sono notevoli
rispetto a quello che a cui siamo
abituati noi c'è possibilità anche qui
c'è la possibilità di scelta possiamo di
scelta che è una cosa bellissima perché
la libertà la libertà ci piace a tutti
oltretutto la libertà è una grande e
potenziamento delle capacità di
apprendimento se fossimo in grado di
amplificare la possibilità di scelta non
riservarla un'ora soltanto decreti
giorni a settimana
le letture sui divani cioè puoi leggere
in un posto imposto confortevole dove
dove puoi anche socializzare con i tuoi
amici dove puoi parlare e chiacchierare
fare yoga fare del relax dei momenti
della giornata in cui si lavora si
studia max ear ci può anche ci si può
anche a riposare o studiare per conto
proprio
laboratori scientifici questi sono molto
belli
erano veramente belli non come nella
scuola che arrivi il professorino tifa
sperimentino qui i ragazzi che lavorano
veramente su cose serie sono i cerchi
serie e e poi anche i tavoli da lavoro
sono grandi
c'è tanta roba per poter fare questi
lavori e ognuno c'è il suo progetto che
porta avanti di o il casco per esempio
il wifi cioè dappertutto
sembra strano ma perché 2 ms cercare
anche oggi ma invece non è proprio così
e corrente elettrica burberi e per
ricaricare i propri device i bagni
guadagli in bagni sono importantissimi
nei bagni non potessero più perché non
hanno la carta igienica per i bagni sono
anche la doccia sono bagni veri sono
bagni finti ecco è questo nel 2035 però
è ancora adesso non è così l'insegnante
in un altro nome è la voce sono
tranquilli pacati parlano con gli
studenti che chiedono informazioni e poi
non stanno lì a spiegare la lezione come
sto facendo io ora no questa cosa non
avviene perché perché perché l'azione
non è detto che debba essere per forza
trasmissiva esistono tanti modi per
imparare le cose anche per auto a
prendere senza bisogno di alcuno ti
spieghi per forza le cose come per
esempio quando fate un corso di lingue
online
imparate benissimo la lingua del
computer addirittura vi ascolta mentre
lui
voi parlate vi fa di far diventare verde
le frasi che vide bene e rosse quelle
che non pronunciate bene quindi un vero
maestro
per esempio imparare l'inglese gli
arresti su un po tutte le materie che
non solamente per l'impero le lingue
straniere perché la cosa più importante
in questa scuola 2035 e che non si
insegnava la la chimica la storia la
filosofia ma si insegnavano le 8
competenze europee che in effetti lo
dovevo essere insegnate anche oggi
perché indicazioni nazionali ne parlano
molto di questa cosa
ne parlavamo indicazion azione però non
tutti ne reggono e quindi la scuola
ancora si insegnano le materie ma è vero
poi si mettono anche i voti suoi
materiali e poi su queste competenze i
voti non si mettono ma se non ogni ogni
tre anni
ma questa queste cose esistono ancora
esistono oggi maldi erano proprio appesa
ai muri stavano scritte sui muri
comunicazione nella madrelingua
comunicazione lingue straniere le
competenze scientifiche la competenza
digitale
2035 c'è la competenza digitale imparare
ad imparare che la regina delle delle
competenze perché con questa si ottiene
tutto la competenza sociale e civica e
saper collaborare insieme collaborare
per imparare e lo spirito d'iniziativa
l'imprenditorialità perché senza queste
cose dalla società non va avanti e la
scuola non sono adesso mi sembra che non
le insegne questa roba però però la
consapevolezza l'espressione cultura the
city adesso si fa tra l'iss aveva fatta
poco praticamente è molto molto diversa
da come lo facciamo noi oggi per esempio
cercano dei corsi che si seguivano che
duravano solo due mesi non corso di
fotografia è più il corso anche il corso
di storia e filosofia di matematica è
uno corsi brevi consideri che duravano
poco intensivi e subito dopo c'era un
piccolo esame e ti facevano vedere forno
può toccare con mano le tue competenze e
se era andato bene poteva passare al
secondo livello terzo quarto quinto
livello
come si fa oggi per esempio per le
lingue straniere ma si può fare per
tutte le discipline o anche o comunque
anche per le competenze
ecco il
la mattina quando si arrivava scusi
arriva a scuola non si trova già
un'attività da svolgere
non è semplicemente non devi aspettare
qualcuno ti faccio lezione 8 interni che
si è già quello che devi fare sta
scritto sul tuo smartphone quindi ti
metti in coppia e lo fai
e anche le attività le attività sono
come sono creative si dà qualcosa da
creare da fare non da ripetere a
pappagallo la lezione no perché ormai
siamo tutti stufi di questo tipo di
apprendimento vogliamo creare vogliamo
fare qualcosa che simili che sia simile
alla realtà perché la scuola deve
diventare qualcosa di ha agganciato alla
realtà non deve essere un museo e si
collabora perché la competizione anche
la competizione deve essere solo era
solo nei gruppi cioè fra i gruppi c'è
competizione non fra le persone e quindi
non ci sente spirito perché oggi ho
preso un brutto voto ma ma ma si sente
incoraggiato perché il mio la mia
squadra magari non ce l'ha fatta ma la
prossima volta ce la farà si deve
produrre un documento c'è un qualcosa di
pratico insieme i bambini lavorano i
ragazzi lavorano insieme perché c'è da
fare qualcosa che deve essere consegnato
entro entro due ore entro la giornata
oppure si deve creare un programma si
deve che ha un software di bambini
insomma non sono in grado di creare
software si insegna si può fare
realizzare un cartellone come adesso
l'ho visto paio già nelle scuole questa
cosa però li aveva fatto molto meglio
perché saper comunicare attraverso
un'immagine e una scritta una cosa
importantissima e lo vediamo tutti i
giorni quando usciamo di casa sul la
televisione sui cartelloni per strada
oppure anche risolvere un problema
complesso è una cosa importante perché
perché quando si dà a uno studente da
risolvere un problema questo studente da
casa tenta di farlo non ci riesce a
chiudere libro se ne va o al massimo
telefono a un amico anzi telefono anzi
diciamo la verità su whatsapp e guarda
che c'è c'è già risolto il problema
tanto non c'è più bisogno di sforzarsi
perché il secchione da grassi dal fatto
da passato a tutti non è così
da questi anche i ragazzi che lo dicono
perché
le chat di chat di di classe cominciano
già a in prima media
forse anche prima che poi finiscono all
ultima non ricevono nei 200 di casa c'è
tutto è praticamente quella vicky piria
è perché sa di tutta oppure la
drammatizzazione sapere saper recitare
la super recitare parlare in pubblico
come stiamo facendo come sto facendo io
adesso ho qua sarebbe una cosa bella
farla scuola attraverso a quasi costini
teatro ma non fatti per chi per chi
vuole sì cioè per chi vuole sì perché
deve essere libero anche questo però
curricolari nel senso non fatti così una
volta tanto ma deve essere inserito come
possibilità di di apprendimento come
tutte le altre competenze discipline all
insegnante non sta in cattedra questa
scuola sta in giro sta in giro per i
gruppi e aiuta eventualmente chi è in
difficoltà che non può andare
tranquillamente da solo
ecco come è fatta la giornata anzi
compito autentico compito creativo come
il fatto è fatto
poi vedrete altri tempi precisi e con
scadenza 5 10 minuti di video lezione a
casa poi un'ora e mezza poi attività in
classe una mezz'ora poi di valutazione
perché così ricevi il feedback è
immediatamente non è che come ti portano
il compito in classe dopo un mese che
l'hai fatto che tu guarda i suoi voto
butti via no non è così
qui immediatamente sai quello che cosa
ha fatto la tua squadra poi perché non
stai lavorando da solo e sempre il tuo
gruppetto la tua copia due tre o quattro
amici con cui state facendo un lavoro
che ti interessa l'orario tipico
giornaliero come boe si entra le 9 dal 9
10 rivedete colazione studio individuale
poi il lavoro vero è solo due ore la
mattina di lavoro di gruppo intenso in
cui c'è una cosa da produrre
si si diceva un feedback e una
valutazione poi sport un'ora di sport
pranzo relax due ore pomeriggio altre
due ore di lavoro insieme e un'altra ora
di sport lo sport è importantissimo non
possiamo dimenticarcelo
lo sport è una cosa molto bella e
scarica e ci ri crea ci ri crea
veramente più di una ricreazione
sono le scuole paga addirittura in
classe ecco è la scuola è aperta anche
saputo da domenica
queste scuole sono aperte anche il
sabato la domenica anche di sera perché
sono sono posti dove le associazioni
dove i gruppi possono organizzare
concerti manifestazioni spettacoli è lì
c'è posto per tutti
c'è un posto dove anche dove divertirsi
non solamente studiare
niente compiti niente compiti a casa
solo video lezioni da vedere perché si
impara a scuola si impara a scuola
facendo facendo il lavoro insieme agli
altri agli altri ragazzi e gli altri
bambini agli altri studenti
gli ebook gli ebook meno porta a scuola
perché non nell'ebook su tutti i libri
che vogliono quindi non ci hanno bisogno
di portarmi la cartellone pesante da
dodici chili come poverino porta a mio
figlio che stavi a 8 anni guardarmi una
cartella e 12 kg a otto anni ho un'età
non era e non è pochissimo questo
bambino
vedete se la sta cavando da solo non
stanno reggendo a portare in giro perché
non sa camminare cadrà non importa però
deve cavarsela da soli
questa è la scuola del futuro nessuno si
deve sentire obbligato a venire a scuola
come nessuno si deve sentire obbligato a
mangiare la cultura il nutrimento della
nostra anima del nostro cuore
ne abbiamo bisogno più del cibo forse
nessuno si deve sentire obbligato e
secondo non vuole studiare si deve
essere aiutato a cercarsi un lavoro
adesso è abbandonato o sospeso 15 giorni
e assurda messo in una famiglia di
cattura per peggiore di quella che noi
immaginiamo non ci sono più titoli di
studio perché nel 2025 stati ammoniti
nessuno
a quel punto va a scuola per un pezzo di
carta e anche i presidi sono non solo
come adesso i paesi sono dei manager
magici culturali che non sono sommersi
dalla burocrazia a una video ship
educativa con la quale collaborano per
mandare avanti questa scuola non ci sono
più bidelli 150mila bidelli abbiamo in
italia per
ma ci sono tutte le cooperative non sono
invitati che stanno a girarsi i pollici
no tutto il giorno perché lo dobbiamo
pulire l'aula mezz'ora prima e comincia
la scuola mezz'ora dopo quando è finita
no c'è una ditta di pulizie fa queste
cose ex alunni però ecco i tablet tablet
vi dicevo sono pieghevoli da 235 quindi
te le porti via teleporti intascano
zainetto con molta più facilità ci sono
anche gli occhiali dove puoi vedere le
immagini basta aspettare
basta aspettare perché perché la cassa e
carota esiste già è tutto quello che ho
fatto vedere sono fotografie vere non
sono fotografia del futuro queste cose
si fanno veramente
abbiamo mille insegnanti in italia che
già lo fanno
abbiamo siamo formati 4 mila come ha
detto andrea adesso in tutto il mondo ci
sono 50 paesi dove questa cosa avviene
perché dobbiamo ancora aspettare noi
abbiamo un modello pedagogico nuovo
fondato sulle competenze che muove molto
simile poi a quello che dico indicazioni
nazionali e che poi nelle scuole non si
fa ecco abbiamo meno oggi uno o due
segnanti per scuola che praticano questa
cosa con il cuore soprattutto perché ci
vuole un cuore un'energia enorme per
fare queste cose perché sembra che
bisognerà remare controcorrente io direi
che ora di partire no guardiamo
attraverso questo mora vi racconta anche
come è stata molto velocemente perché ho
solamente due secondi ecco è scaduto
questi sono i primi il primo libro che
leggiamo nel 2013 e questa era la nostra
classe che è diventata colore e dopo
aver cominciato queste cose è bellissimo
vedere vedere i ragazzi che cambiano
cambiano perché ci dicono che sono
contenti perché usano i computer perché
lavorano in gruppo e questo è un mio
alunno si chiama diego sa proprio che
lei spiega proprio bene la chimica e io
gli dissi ma quelli non ti ho mai
spiegato chimica periodo dall'uso di
strumenti perché tu possa prendere da
solo aiuto aiutato quando c'erano dei
lavori di gruppo
però lui mi disse però però guardi cosa
lei mi faccio il favo insegne questo
metodo tutti i professori d'italia e lo
stiamo facendo con muta con molta calma
perché siamo in pochi
siamo in pochi lo facciamo certe volte
anche come volontariato perché per fare
la classica vuota bisogna cambiare una
cosa che c'è in tutte le scuole del
mondo guardate queste sono le scuole
in india portate quelle cosa c'è di
uguale in tutte queste in madagascar
cosa c'è di uguale in tutte queste cose
che state vedendo tu in tutto il mondo
avviene questa cosa anche se bambina nel
burqa come qui è anche nelle scuole per
adulti addirittura nella scuola per
carcerati da ogni parte del mondo di
insegnante è l'attore come me e voi
siete gli spettatori non va bene questa
non è scuola questa va bene prima di te
dx ma non è ma non per la scuola non
siamo persone che riempiono il cervello
dei nostri alunni non dobbiamo riempire
le teste vuote non è più accettabile
oggi siamo nel 2018 si può fare qualcosa
gli studenti hanno diritto a una scuola
che non si sa come quella di un secolo
fa chiedete e quindi ai vostri docenti
di formarsi chiedetelo perché lo possono
fare
oggi in usa danno stai veneto mostrando
tantissimi soldi come aveva mai successo
per la formazione e gli insegnanti
credete che i vostri intendimenti si
formino perché facciano lavoro di gruppo
perché incentivano digitale wifi le
materie facoltative perché facciano
video lezioni perché facciano la classe
capovolta perché chiama la scuola va
ribalta piazza
[Applauso]